this is your city you have the chance to
realize your purpose
[Music]
Green Arrow and the Canaries the episode
that we've all been waiting for is
finally here and I'm so excited because
the coolest Canaries that I know are
here in studio at UT patrolling on it
thank you so much for coming in it's
Girl it's naughty to be here oh my
goodness this is an episode that fans
have been so excited for since it was
first announced what was it like
stepping into this backdoor pilot I mean
it was a it was amazing it was it was
what's nice about it is it feels fresh
but it still lives and has the same
aesthetic and it still lives in the same
world but it just it was just it's the
shut the episode the show is just it
takes it to another level
it elevates things in a way and it was
fun especially like for our characters
you know what they've gone through to
get to this point where they're at and
their reasoning why and discovering you
know from for Laurel earth to learning
more about her her her background we
know a little bit not a lot and just you
know women kicking ass yeah and a lot of
action and that it definitely is the
time it's definitely a time for that and
you know it's yeah it's incredible out
of it we would just honestly felt so
grateful we've just been so overwhelmed
with gratitude to have this opportunity
we're like all of these things this
possibility of a continuation of this
world exists and like it's women and
it's us and our family and we get to say
together so yeah it weird like we're so
happy and excited absolutely and so this
is a very special episode basically fans
are getting a peek as to what could be a
new arrow spin-off how does that feel
for you guys knowing that this is a
backdoor pilot did you feel any pressure
when you were going into it there's
definitely definitely pressure but won't
for me anyway it was more excitement and
more I was I love you know in terms of
the writers and how they've written for
me and as an actor like I love the arcs
and then just like the different
characters and the different versions
and I like to sink my teeth and they're
like good character background stuff and
so I was more excited and it was a say
yeah say yeah I was interestingly I
think I felt more pressure going into
arrow
because it already existed and there was
like a world to come into and that I
felt pressure as soon as I met everybody
the pressure was gone but coming into
this it was like excitement like we can
do what we want and we can create
something new and so it's more just like
having a blank canvas yeah yeah
definitely let's talk a little bit about
the premise of this first episode we're
coming in of course after a crisis on
Infinite Earths which was a lot seen a
little bit for the fans what can they
expect from this first episode I would
say not necessarily what they're gonna
see expect the unexpected I guess
totally um but you know it's it's you
see many different versions of you sorta
again that that same feeling of being
elevated and that even it goes up far
even with the characters in the
chemistry between Jules and I you know
it's light but at the same time you know
we're still in the arrowverse and
there's familiar yeah absolutely yeah
I'm gonna just stop saying so without
giving away too much information you'll
see a lot of characters who fan fan
favorites and you'll see them and grow
and be in different positions than maybe
you thought yeah arrow with a Oh Erin
with the twist it's like a martini yeah
and then at the end you're like I was in
the first episode yes there's a final
scene in this I'm not gonna spoiler for
you guys but oh my goodness gracious
it really just ties everything up and
leaves you wanting more which is really
mine um Katie you've been part of arrow
from the very beginning now here we are
eight years later with this new
potential spin-off how are you feeling
about this next chapter of your life
honestly I mean I'm so Giuliana said it
you know gratitude grateful thankful you
know
every one these people you know we
become a family
and what's really what's really been
cool is all not just myself but other
writers even best shorts actually you
know arrow has been something for us
that really elevated all of us and
allowed us to grow as artists and for me
it's been I have had a chance to direct
and I think that it feels as though like
that's sort of my sweet spot I don't
know I just I it was incredible and you
get to see other Beth she's starting as
a as an assistant and now she is a
showrunner and she's an incredible woman
and it's just it's been so amazing
because we've been given so much
opportunity and it's cool to just get to
see people grow and evolve cameramen you
know our DP has directed our James
Bamford he started as our stunt
coordinator and now he was he had become
obviously an incredible director but
also executive producer and so you get
to grow with these people and so I'm
just I'm excited and hopefully you know
we continue to get to grow together as a
family and yeah well I'm so glad that
you brought up your directorial debut
because I wasn't able to chat with you
for it you were so busy filming yeah but
if this series continues would you be
open to directing again oh yes I
actually I've asked and I you know I
definitely want to I mean I love
directing it's it's amazing and it's
everything that I don't know it it felt
very second nature for me but also such
a great wonderful educational experience
in terms of doing the Warner Brothers
directors program which I did and and it
just it's so nice to have that
collaboration and having all the heads
of departments come together and bring
your vision to life and so it was really
it was really special and I had a blast
and I can't wait to direct more it's
great for the actors too because you
know when you have your team mate
they're like you know it's it's it's a
different kind of vibe on set and it's a
it's just a different it's it's better
it's it's like familiar and it's just um
yeah
I really want you to direct like thank
you like you're really she's very
talented thank you I feel like also
because I'm an actor what I felt was
really beneficial as other actors they
feel safe that's yeah it is with me that
you want to be wrong no yeah that's
exactly what I'm trying to say yeah it's
safe yeah so that was good yeah thank
you and thank you yeah really um I am so
excited because in one of the promo
photos we saw that the lovely Giuliana
is giving us a different canary cry in
this episode we see Dinah more of a
singing yes canary ditty
I'm so excited talk to me about how this
came about were you nervous are you
excited your voice is sensational things
incredible things amazing thank you it
came about I think because our writers
follow me on Instagram and saw that I
play instruments and they were like hey
that's really good would you and Beth
called me one day and just said would
you want be interested in playing for
the show and it was it was it felt
second only to finding out that this
show was happening I was so excited it
was actually like a dream come true
really and something that I had been
nervous to do in the past because music
always felt more intimate to me and and
like I'm sharing my soul as opposed to
playing a character and you kind of
share that character so so I was like
this is like the universe telling me
that I have to be brave because I'm not
going to say no and then they were
really collaborative and they allowed me
to help choose the song they allowed me
to write my own song and see if we
wanted to use that for this episode and
it was like the most fun day on set I
felt really in like my element to kind
of how you were with directing that's
how I felt
playing so I want music to be a big part
of this show personally because actually
all of us can sing and play music and I
think it was just really proud to thank
yeah she's incredible and I love that
they're giving you know they're adding
that sort of it's it's something new
again the element of being fresh right
right it's growing and having other
opportunities yeah positive all very
special things yeah I have a very
special thing
question for you guys right now and so
go ahead and look right here on the
monitor and we'll play it for you I'm so
good I couldn't be there with Mike right
you're on set for another project but
I'm with you in spirit and I thought I'd
give you a question of my own I wanted
to know what your favorite moment of
shooting this episode was we have cat be
part of this yeah filming a different
project right now but I was like all
right let's get her involved she said in
a fan question yeah I love that girl so
your favorite part of filming this
episode oh my gosh that's so tough I
think the moments where we were all
together in costume after we had like
you know just like accomplished our
thing and I'm not gonna give anything
away
we was just together as a group as a
team and like just feeling that energy
of all of us together and our power and
like knowing that we have this whole
future ahead of us like they're just a
few there were different points in
different scenes where I felt that way
but I don't just being with these girls
like made me feel really good about the
episode I was sorry I'm just trying to
think it I think it was yeah so there's
a scene where we enter I don't wanna
give any spoilers away but a certain
location and basically I have this long
monologue and I basically take a glass
yes and it's the moment that she
realizes that you know she's she catches
the glass as I'm testing her and she's
like holy SH I am she has these skills
already in that live was in her and so
she starts to realize that this is the
world she sort of starts to step into
but what was really cool about this
scene also the last scene in the episode
where we clink glasses but what was
really cool about this scene it was we
couldn't it we were struggling to find
it and what was awesome is again it's
the collaboration and not that scene at
the end it was also sort of like we were
coming together and I went ahead moment
yeah the other one was like we were
collaborating and you know even the
director and
I've been like trying to just find it
and figure it out and I love that it and
it was awesome it's time for you to be
the green arrow I remember yeah it was
yeah it was felt very organic as a
viewer to be able to watch that as well
I love the fact that this is such a
great time for female empowerment what
are the chances that this green arrow
and the canaries backdoor pilot is
coming out this same month that birds of
prey is coming out in theatres yeah
things happen in cycles like that but
you know why I think it's good I think
like again the female empowerment mm-hmm
that's awesome
like they're all of the actors mother
Robby you are invited to come to my
photo please
if you want to come maybe do a little
cameo we would totally be fine any of
those girls do you think that's
something that you guys would be open to
yeah I mean if margot robbie called
hello sorry margot let me know i
seriously though i think it's a it's a
cool thing that it's happening at the
same time because and one of the themes
of our show and the way that we
interpret the comic and the story is
that especially with our character there
can be more than one it's not about
there is one black canary dances but
it's like any woman can be the black
canary
it's about this and it's about your
integrity and it's about you know your
inner strength and then how you and so i
think it's kind of cool because it sets
that standard like on a bigger level
with our character to have it in the
movies and in and one person and also
having biracial black Canary's on both
ends very very good so this whole thing
is really good and i think that we're
all moving towards something that's
bigger and better in a world that's
bigger and better and that's why this
show is important yeah absolutely
very well said very very well good I
love that you're talking about the fact
that you know obviously we can't have so
many different characters in there you
guys are really giving us a completely
different twist on things we're
back again in 2040 what are some
characters that you would love to see
appear in this series right anyone from
the arrowverse or from the DC comics oh
well I can't tell you I'm just saying
maybe arrow Oh
unlike my brain is still broken from
crisis I'm just but it's it's really
cool because since it's still set in the
DC world we can't have it opens up in
the world to so many new characters of
course yeah absolutely I mean anything
is possible in this world in this
universe so yeah there is no arrowverse
anymore there's all of us together so
anyone from any one of these worlds I
mean look in like you know I would love
to like have cuz Harley Quinn is birds
of prey right so what if we had like the
Joker on our show who's the Joker has to
be a male yes by the way why can't I
play The Joker wonder why she's a
director yes hello the white hair you a
little messy mascara actually Stewart
Joker photo shoot yeah but anyways
alright no track this episode is of
course our second-to-last episode of
arrow of all time I've got to talk to
you about the series finale when you
guys read that script what was your
initial reaction how many tears were
there just from the first page just
weeping heaving stuff yeah it's just
yeah I it's still it's like so surreal
still I think you know it takes a second
to like all I know is well actually I'm
not gonna say anything but I almost just
yeah also gave away some things right
now
[Applause]
Leyna you guys almost got me almost yeah
oh so emotional we were all a wreck I
mean we were all just breaking it was
good because we were all there for each
other everyone was breaking down at
random times and it's cuz we realized
how much we loved each other and how
grateful we were and again it's just
like this new series is being born out
of so much love out of so much hard work
out of just thousands of people and ours
and you know of like creating this world
that's that's amazing so to see it come
to an end was so intense but then also
to had to keep it going is so amazing
yeah lastly what is the one thing that
you want arrow fans to know before they
tune in to this special episode well
thank you yeah for all the support and
we wouldn't be here this long if it
weren't for the fans and you know
continuous like for tuning in
also they're in for a for a wild ride
yeah oh definitely yeah just thank you I
mean truly like you are what it's almost
like this is a fantasy world that we
create at work but then you come into
the picture and then it becomes real
because you know you share your stories
with us and you and we do it for you and
we do we literally do it for you so
thank you thank you yeah
[Music]